even understood my question right away I
think that he heard me say the word
doubt and he probably deals with a lot
of people who ask him questions and he
he just gets annoyed but let me put it
like this here even if you came to me if
you came to me today in front of the CA
and said well I have a bit of a doubt
I'm not going to come and see to you in
front of the C how you having a doubt I
have to assume the best and say hold on
a second it can be a doubt there's
nothing look doubt there's two things
you do with so that doesn't make you a
cafer to have a doubt not
a I am a Reaver and I was taught how to
pray Sal that means every single time I
pray the person who told me gets the
reward five times a day from F to is if
you want to support someone like me in
learning Salah then sponsor 10 people
for just 00 this Ramadan remember the
prophet peace be upon him said charity
does not decrease wealth click the
button and donate
now brothers and sisters and dear
friends hope you guys are well inshallah
as we told you guys alhamdulillah we was
here invited here by Allah subhana wa
tala but before that actually in the
council group that we're in he said Ali
why don't you come to Mecca and I said
I'm so busy with the lives every single
day I'm doing a live my wife saying
actually she goes you're not I don't
even see you and subh Allah I said to
her bite your tongue inah cuz at the end
of the day U we got 100 we need $150,000
to print 50,000 mats alhamdulillah and
we're opening Salah hubs all across the
UK and Europe um and we've got the app
coming out inshallah and there's so many
projects going with Salah plus project
as you guys already know so so um he
invited and I thought you know what
actually it' be nice to do live with
them there cuz Jo are live every year
anyways so he said why do you come here
we'll do it here I said she we love you
online with the pixels it would be
better to see you in person so we came
here and we had surprise over surprise
because then heard that sneak here I
Adam slim whole Brothers everyone is
here sub yes Lord go aldah that we got a
plan with him with about Nas da but
that's going to come out later don't
worry in you know they do Jan pray here
we're going to be doing that inshah but
that's a different topic so so um let's
get straight into inah I don't want to
hold it any too too longer sne there was
a question that you asked um ask a
question again please if you can ask a
question again I I probably phrase it
incorrectly um well for for say it the
way you said it don't wor so that
there's a Hadith that I read that I've
been struggling with uh comprehending
properly and and fully uh believing in
if I'm being honest and the Hadith reads
uh the PE Prophet Muhammad sallam said
the people of Yemen are the best people
and when I read that it was conflicting
because the reason I became Muslim
because it gots rid of racial Supremacy
and there's a famous Hadith from the
prophet s where he says that uh there's
no race that's Superior than the other
we're all created equal and we're judged
based off what's in our hearts so I ask
you shman how could there be no racial
Supremacy within Islam but also the
people of Yemen be the best of people
excellent first thing alhamdulillah
that's a great question and
alhamdulillah in Islam we encourage you
to ask when you don't
know go and ask the people of knowledge
so the people of knowledge should never
discourage anybody from asking a
question not going to kick you out of
anywhere we invite you to and welcome
you to come and ask questions and you
know we don't want to waste time on
people that don't want to know the truth
but anybody who's searching for the
truth as I see you being we never
discourage them from asking anything you
know and we will answer it inshallah by
the will of subhana tala with clear
evidences and then and we accept that
from us that we are Muslim we submit to
it but we should always ask so the first
thing is the Hadith you're
referencing this is mentioned in a that
is mentioned by the IM Ahmed in his and
other this there is a problem in the
chain of it so this is something we need
to this is why everybody should
understand some of the of
the inl it
mentions that that IM is is a cah from
the people of Yemen and wisdom is
something that is from Yemen it does not
include this section that you mention
that the best men are the men of Yemen
right
[Music]
so is a he's the one that reports this
from
Abu one of the early Scholars who
recorded theth said that the that the
are all good except the fact that never
met Abu Hur so there's a break in
between those two right and because the
stronger narration which is in sahkari
and Muslim doesn't have that wording so
what is correct is that no doubt the in
Muslim this is this is what is the
correct wording so what does that mean
that no we don't say that the best of
men are any particular nationality
because what we know is the most
authentic and clearth on the subject
tells
us there is no virtue of the on the
non-arab or the aam or the Arab on black
or white except in tawa whoever is more
Pious is closer to Allah subhana wa tala
now there are a Hadith that mention the
virtue of the people of Yemen as there
are a Hadith that mention the virtue of
the people of sham of the people that
are in current day lant which is Syria
uh Lebanon Jordan and Palestine may
Allah free it so this area that is about
how in the end of time this is where IM
will be preserved and so on that means
that wasallam praised different people
about different virtues that they had
not showing that one is superior by DNA
over another the Romans too the Roman of
course and and even like for example I
mean let's be real about this right if I
was to say you know the Egyptians could
build pyramids like if you want to talk
about building great structures at that
time that's Egyptian right that doesn't
mean that every Egyptian knows how to
build a pyramid it doesn't mean that
they're better than anybody else it's
praising a particular skill set that
they had if I said man the people of
India in mathematics they came with the
concept of zero math is from India or
logic and philosophies from the Greek
right yes but that doesn't mean that
they're Superior by any DNA right we're
we don't believe in a chosen people of
God we believe that everybody is equal
in front of Allah subhana tala and Allah
chooses who he wishes that's why a
prophet was sent to every nation so
there were prophets that were Arab there
were prophets that are not Arabs there
were prophets who were black there are
prophets who were white prophets of
every dist nationality and they're the
best of mankind is the prophets right
even amongst the sahaba the companions
of the Prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam we had people like bhashi and
he was from the best of sahabah and you
had likei and you had Salman Al fari
even when the Arab would talk about
their lineage the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam would say that Salman
far he was a Persian man it's from my
household you know from the people his
household why to show that we are not
tied through nationalism rather through
Iman when the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam mentions Al Muhammad the family
of Muhammad many of the when they
explain this they said this includes all
of the Believers why because we are like
the children of the prophet in that
spiritual sense right so this is to be
clear that in Islam we do not believe
that any particular race is superior to
the other by DNA having said that no
doubt the people of Yemen were a very
wise people and at that time they were
people of faith when they entered Islam
they were they were strong in their
Islam and that virtue was there no doubt
and every I mean just to be real I mean
like I don't believe in being fake I
don't do political correctness you know
I'm I'm straight about this right no
doubt certain races do have certain
skill sets either right look I mean yeah
I know it's not going to be politically
correct answer but I don't care right
like if if I was to say that
African-Americans in America are good at
basketball that not I'm not being racist
right I mean look at the percentage of
African-Americans in the US and look at
the percentage that's black in the MBA
right or or NFL and so on if I was to
say that people of China are excellent
at table tennis it doesn't mean that
they're not is that they have a skill
set I'm not I know this wokeism thinks
that we cannot mention things like this
but it's true right certain people have
certain characteristics that doesn't
mean every Chinese good at good at table
tennis right it doesn't mean every black
man can ball like when I was in high
school I had a lot of friends that were
tall African-American brothers and
everybody expected them to be good
basketballers and they weren't that
doesn't mean everyone right but these
certain characteristics are there and
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
praised different people for different
characteristics including the Persians
you know he prays he said if knowledge
was in the stars there would be a
Persian that would go to grab it you
know that doesn't mean that they're
better than anybody else right but as we
see in the Next Generation some of the
greatest Scholars of Islam including an
Arabic Grammer sa away including in
Hadith the likes of alkari including in
like the likes abif and so on they were
Persians right so in Islam in closing
first thing always ask any question you
have never feel shy and inshallah by the
will of Allah subh with evidences like I
did right now we will give you the
answer and secondly we do not believe in
this superity of any race per DNA but we
do believe that at times certain people
stand up for certain principles and they
should be praised for that like the
ansar the people of Madina even though
the prophet is not from Madina but he
said to love them is a part of IM why
because the service they did for Islam
right when the prophet praised the best
army to be the one that conquered
Constantinople and we know that was in
the time of the Ottoman Empire right
when he talked about so many different
virtues of different people we
appreciate people and that their work
but the authentic clear Hadith tells us
that there is no virtue of anybody per
DNA except whoever is more close to
Allah in piety will be the one that is
superior I mean one thing I just want to
say before I give to sneo is that oh
sorry yeah one thing that I will say
before I get sneo because at the end day
I came to Islam 11 12 years ago and I
know how certain things I'll be honest
with you I can remember the first year
when I came to Islam I was walking in
Stratford and I was just on my phone
like look some information I heard that
the sahaba fought each other and our
Cameran here ran he had the same thing I
was shocked I actually had to sit down I
said what the sahab fought each other
and then I heard that the prophet wife
and what I was like like it hit me like
someone punched me in the face cuz in
our head we have this false reality and
we we bring and we we do this a lot of
times and I was like how could the best
like how could they fight each other but
the point is when I went to someone to
get the answered if he was to come and
say to me like how you you got
uncertainty now again I want to give a
disclaimer I was in double Minds about
doing this because the had a f against a
specific show I was doing and I respect
his opinion I've always said you know
what and even yourself I know you have
the op and I respect that as long as we
are brothers myself I went to an Alim
who gave me the fat to go ahead and I
understand as long as we're brothers we
have a difference opinion I didn't want
to do the video because I didn't want it
to come across as if I'm having to go
the I'm in front of the the C
is if I have anything against the
because of that what he said there was
pass that was true and I apologized I
the was true H and I even apologized for
that and even repented for that I didn't
want to do that video because it come
across like that but when I saw the
video sneaker as a Reaver I was like you
shouldn't be made to feel that you can't
ask questions we have Christians who
come to Islam and go I went to the
church and asked a question about
Trinity I said oh you you've got
something wrong with your faith no you
should not be made to feel and I don't
think the shef did it on purpose we just
say that it was and and the enemies of
Islam are trying to use this because
Islam is growing and and and can't
really blame them and they see Islam is
growing people come into Islam we
understand your pain we hear your pain
it hurts it hurts yeah but you need to
have some simple feel mean okay yeah I I
don't think he even understood my
question right away I think that he
heard me say the word doubt and he
probably deals with a lot of people who
ask him questions and he he just gets
annoyed but let me put it like this here
even if you came to me if you came to me
today in front of the CA and said well I
have a bit of a doubt I'm not going to
come and see to you in front of the ca
how you having a doubt I have to assume
the best and say hold on a second it can
be a doubt actually there's nothing look
doubt there's two things you do so that
doesn't make you a CF to have a doubt
no if that's the case me I've left Islam
when I first came there was some
questions I asked bro that you do two
things with doubts and I'm mentioning
this for those who have doubts number
one you have a doubt and what you do is
you let that grow number two you say I
have a doubt I want to go to a person of
knowledge and I want to ask and say I
have a genuine doubt let me give you an
example at the time of the Prophet wasam
a man came to the prophet and said oh
messenger of Allah we have thoughts in
our head about Allah and his messenger
that we will rather fall from the sky
and be eaten up by birds did the say you
had thought about me and Allah out get
not out take his if the prophet move
some the sa will take him out straight
away now what about the man who came and
said oh of Allah make Z permissible for
me did he say to a prophet you come to
you're coming to a prophet to make what
sexual intercourse permissible you
didn't say that he said look let's
understand would you want that for your
mother oh by Allah would not your
daughter by Allah I want your auntie by
Allah I want he understood the point he
said then why do you want to do it to
other people what about the man who came
in weed in the AK he weed in the mosque
did he come and say Stone him he said
let him finish did you say weed we we
urinated in the UK we say
yeah we call it call it we we I'm joking
urinated so he re urinated so the thing
is
this yeah so uh yeah yeah okay so he Aki
amen we're filming
Aki two seconds please come catch him
catch him look at him I'm trying to run
away okay so the prophet didn't come and
say stop him immediately he said let him
finish number one he cared about his
health because to stop being urinating
in the middle it it can be harmful you
know if anyone's held their urination
back he didn't come and do that the
prophet s wasallam that's why Allah says
in the Quran if you was harsh with them
they would have run away away from you
so my thing was this AI I felt like what
happened and certain things I want go
into detail but look bro anytime it's
close to anybody who's a new Muslim or a
born Muslim who has a sh there is
nothing wrong with coming and asking do
not feel shy do not feel you're going to
be scolded it should not be like that so
that's just one thing I wanted to say
inah and because I've said this before
to you with the whole situation with
Andrew and this that we ask Allah to
guide him but to me bro I'm so sorry I
don't bro let me be honest with I don't
praise you because I want a cookie from
you I don't let be honest with you
there's you're my brother in Islam I
speak we judge like om said we used to
judge from stop we judge from what's
apparent now I see that in you so when I
see that in you bro I only praise you
because I see your dedication into it
subh Allah like the Japanese sister who
came from a specific whever yeah Subhan
Allah I saw the sincerity of her
repentance crying in Jil praying F she's
been a Muslim for six months yeah and
sub Allah anyways I don't get to this
Andrew T two and a half years anyways
yeah so yeah no no I'm very angry
because you know why and you're coming
and attacking Muslims and blaming us for
attacks that we didn't do yeah but
anyways because our sisters who are
walking on the streets get attacked
because of your C anyway so the the the
point is that that even that sister subh
she got in contact with our Salah team
was sending her a guided prayer map yeah
and and our sister f is going to teach
how to praise Salah step by step and by
the way those who are watching she's
going to join our stream on the 27th
night in yeah and we're going to hear
her story but sneo if you have any other
questions bro here's the chance if you
want to any other doubts or things you
have no that was a major one and I think
it's important to to talk about these
things that's why I felt comfortable
asking that question because the reason
I became Muslim was because it's a
logical religion it's people saying that
it's a cold or that it's Blind Faith and
the reason that I left is because Blind
Faith things like the Trinity never made
sense just believe don't ask questions
I've been told that by priest before
just believe it but that never made
sense and you know I came to realize
that I always was Muslim because when I
grew up I wasn't praying the Holy Spirit
I wasn't praying to Mary or St Anthony I
was praying to God exactly so the logic
behind Islam is why I'm Muslim and it
has nothing to do with any cult or any
anything people are trying to say to
disparage it because they're not
actually looking into the the context of
the conversation or the Hadith that was
mentioned yeah exactly and another thing
that for example example the she said
you know he didn't mean it is that about
the prophet marriage to AA you know
you're C that wasn't even the question I
was asking no no I know I know but when
he said you're C I was shocked like we
were so shocked yeah and maybe I don't
know why maybe this had a specific style
but look like for example you hold the
opinion that was not six yeah I don't
ahe tell me yeah so like for for me I
believe she was six and the cons that
nine the issue is not that the issue is
even if someone came and ask that to
hold the opinion to come and say you
know is a c I was shocked so by the
clarify yeah I do want to clarify I know
a lot of people keep thinking this but
sorry forgive me I I video saying it
that's why I didn't say it's my opinion
I'll explain it sorry sorry so this
reputation of Ali no no I don't do
reputations but uh clarifications at
times but and just this is a point um
you know Subhan Allah a lot of people
hate and and I don't really care about
the haters but I'll tell you sneo Subhan
Allah he's got a lot on his plate he's
got a fight coming up he's got training
uh I got a Adam Sal as well Adam where
you at I calling you out bro mallah he's
got a fight coming up Slim's training
with him all these brothers all these
brothers were
busy it just found out just kidding
right um but Subhan Allah when when we
said hey let's go for they left their
training they left all of that they came
right and that's a SI of IM they're not
getting paid to be here right the whole
point is that alhamdulillah they
appreciated the opportunity they came
sneo many times you know may Allah
reward him I just want to clarify this
you he's reached out to me and he's
asked me questions and he can be a
witness to this I've never kicked you
out of my house or hung up on you or
anything right we've always taken the
time to answer even today when you asked
this question was the answer clear yeah
good you're good with that now right so
we clarify these issues and every time
I've given sneo any kind of advice like
if he's doing something wrong if I give
him advice he's open to it and he
accepts it and you know everybody has
shortcomings but I appreciate that about
him Ali was the same thing me and Ali da
are brothers in Islam and whoever hates
me for loving him you can hate all you
want right he may hold views that I
don't hold and I may hold view that he
doesn't hold and he may have mistakes
and I may have mistakes but that doesn't
mean we're not Brothers in Islam even if
I am a sinful person that doesn't mean
he should cut me off that means he
should reach out to me he should make
Dua for me he should come and give me
and even if I don't accept it he should
make Dua Abu and IM Malik they met
together in Medina and they disagreed on
so many subjects but they didn't stop
praying behind each other they didn't
stop sitting with each other they didn't
cut each other off they even they had a
debate as some of the mentioned that
they were so Fierce that they had sweat
coming but they came out praising each
other right so we as Muslims have to be
able to meet that mature I know
everybody online just want to see me
refute Ali or Ali refute me but that
we're not going to do this cuz you know
why CU they save the drama for their for
their mama there you go give me that
give me that don't leave me don't leave
me hang in there bro save the drama for
your
mama there a context of that yeah it
means the context of that just because I
don't know a lot of people in the UK
took it the wrong way in the US I think
people understand is that your mother
loves you and nobody loves you like your
mother right so when you have some
emotional Outburst you just wanna you
just want to complain you just want to
have some drama go sit down with your
mother put your head on her lap and and
give her your story she'll she'll put
your head and she'll give you a warm cup
of milk and she'll tolerate you cuz we
won't do that we won't and I don't have
time for all that drama you know so save
the drama for your mama CU she loves you
right right
so regarding the age of now I want to
clarify some things because even some of
our brothers they they they they become
as as if this is like a credle core AA
issue like I mean and again I haven't
watched the video but from what I heard
some somebody said oh if you don't
believe you're C or whatever first thing
this is not a a issue right when when we
believe in Allah we believe in the
prophet we believe in the Mala the books
of of that Allah has revealed the day of
judgment good and bad and all of this is
not the age of secondly it's not in the
Quran right it's not a part of the of
the Quran SEC thirdly what is from
theith is what the prophet Sall alaihi
wasallam told us the prophet never told
us the age of in
no that reaches the prophet Sall
wasallam what we have is aith and I have
no doubt to the authenticity of the
Hadith people were like oh you're
doubting Hadith in bukari never when did
I ever say that we have aith
that said that the engagement was at 6
and the marriage was at 9 in Muslim also
no doubt to the of it right she said I
was seven and married at night so if
somebody says if you don't believe in
six you're cfir what happened say
Muslim one of the classes colors I'm not
reinterpreting anything in the Muslim he
said it could be that she was between
those ages or she wasn't sure about the
exact age so that mean this is not
something that she was witnessing she's
amazing narrator in Hadith no doubt to
her right right now my stance is that it
is very possible that she was six or
seven at engagement and they waited for
her to hit blue for her to be mature
whether that's age of nine or around
that age and they got married and I have
no issues with that but I did mention
that there are
other and others in their that looking
at give different ages I'm not saying
that's my view I'm just presenting that
those are in the early Scholars of Islam
so this is not something like as if we
were just restarting this issue at our
time what is my stance is that I believe
in the of but she is not reporting
something she saw right she's giving
something which is from secondhand
information and the fact that she
mentioned six and seven meaning this not
there not something that she's giving in
Precision this is a roundabout age and
we know that she was already engaged at
the time that means according to the
according to the the the the customs of
the time this was the age that women
would be engaged and she was engaged to
a mus and when Allah revealed the
prophet that you should marry her that
engagement was broken secondly they
waited until she was physically mature
for marriage right that means that she
had hit bu before consummation of
marriage once a woman's body is
physically ready then nature is telling
you that she's ready for child birth and
marriage and if the customs of that time
do not have
any anything stopping from it then of
course like in our time people go to
high school and college and all they
don't have any of that when a man was
old enough to earn his living he would
get married when a woman was old enough
to have children and on a house they
would get married so the fact that they
waited until she was at path physical
puberty meaning according to the customs
of the time they were married now was
she six or seven or nine or 10
it's going to be in that range but we
cannot say that no if you don't believe
that exactly at this age it happened
your cap where do we get this from right
rather we say that she was at an age and
a physical maturity that was correct
according to the of the time and we
don't we don't believe in presentism
meaning judging the past by today's in
fact in the United States until 1890 in
Delaware the age for consummation was
seven seven seven I'll send you the book
theuk I read that book I thought it was
seven yeah it's called British Comm La
age of seven in England you know and not
even in today and that's consummation by
the way that's not engagement also in
America 250,000 guilds at the age of 12
13 and 14 get married my middle school
had a daycare center that mean 12 13y
old kids already had Wilson Middle
School were having children to be honest
they accus the with this thing but I'll
be honest with you Allah humiliates
because most of you I'll be honest with
you pedophilia if you look at it the
ones who are blamed with of this white
middleaged men I'm not every white man
in that category until yeah what and
they changed it to okay yeah so this is
I'll send you this
as and just just as one last point for
those that try to throw rocks sitting in
Glass Houses Rashi go look up his
commentary according to the Bible itself
remember the age of not in the Quran but
according to the Bible itself according
to Rashi the the best and most accepted
commentary by Christians and Jews and
you can look up just go to YouTu put put
up Rashi r a shi commentary and listen
to Jews and Scholars and Christians
praise Rashi he said that according to
the Bible itself Rebecca was 3 years old
when she consummated her marriage she
was married to a
40-year-old Isaac and she is she is
legally according to Jewish law at 3
years of age able to fully be married
but did he wait for her to become an
adult there is nothing like that in the
B sure about this yes look up Rashi it's
not my opinion rash sounds rash Rashi no
no Rashi is a Jewish commentator 12th
century okay and he is highly praised as
the greatest commentator of the Old
Testament in fact according to the
earliest Christian documentation about
the age of Joseph and I'll send you
scans of all of these Joseph was 90
years old when he married a 12-year-old
Mary Mary was 12 years old married to a
90-year old man today if that happened
what would you call that of course so
are you saying Joseph was a pedophile
and Mary was being you know right you
don't see that right in fact in the
gospel of James it also mentions and
this is not in the Bible today this one
of the other books it mentions clearly
that Mary was 12 years
old went in the house I'm with you I'm
with you sir
you did I clarify
my and that's we're here with the champs
as you can
see sne in the
building yes and any reverts out there
Etc again look like I said we should
obviously assume the best of maybe it
was a style whatever but just want we
want you guys to know that do not feel
shy if you have a doubt it does not make
you disbeliever you can come and ask uh
questions please feel free if anyone
makes you feel like oh I have a doubt
and they say to you you have a you go
read the Quran we're there we're there
in videos are there many people's videos
are there to clarify for you guys and
that's it may Allah bless and preserve
you guys all
in about to do best night